coffee on a Tuesday in block 23 in an
art studio oh sorry I was just checking
the the Twitter app on my iPhone someone
someone tweeted me actually that was
like a minute ago now I'm reading the
New York Times a an article about the
Syrian uprising really interesting
really devastating too but actually that
was like a minute ago - now or no no
that actually that was 20 minutes ago I
guess you can really get lost in Temple
Run if I was a kid aged 8 to 18 these
last few minutes would consists only of
a fraction of the seven and a half hours
a day that I spend with media do I care
not really by which I mean of course
that there's a fat chance that I'm gonna
stop doing seven and a half hours that's
from a study conducted by the Kaiser
Family Foundation in 2009 up about an
hour and a half from the same study done
in 2004 so now in 2012 I think it's safe
to say that we're probably pretty close
to eight hours what's the day into nice
even thirds right eight hours of the day
we sleep eight hours of the day we
consume media like rabid hungry wolves
and eight hours of the day we what do we
do for the other eight hours of the day
so what's to be made of all this I don't
want to criticize those who spend a lot
of time with media clearly your
relationship with media like everything
else is your own thing your unoffending
missing from the Kaiser Family
Foundation's report see today's media is
social which means that it consists not
only of consumption but also of
expression and these two things are
relentlessly intertwine whatever you
consume has been expressed by someone
else and whatever you express will be
consumed by others there is a total
awareness of this in social media
Facebook and Twitter are not journals or
Diaries whatever you post on there is
posted with your complete understanding
that others will see it and not only see
it but probably will comment on it and
thus express themselves for your own
responsive consumption and so a facebook
status like a novel or a vlog is a
request for judgment any cereal tweeter
who tells you that he or she doesn't
care what others think should be laughed
at shared expression is the definition
of caring what others think there's such
a thing as expression for its own sake
but that's what these are for the point
is that whatever medium of shared
expression you choose will be the medium
by which you are asking to be judged if
all we're getting from you in terms of
expression is currently up in bed with
the salad in a movie until the Grammys
start odd finally relaxed feels so nice
your guests crack was a little too whack
for Whitney Houston she did eat on a
Saturday night man I'm a loser
homemade crab rangoon or you have to
participate relentlessly in the
manifestations of your own blessings
what don't be surprised if you're
treated equally as simple equally as try
equally as idiotic we should never
forget or forego the understanding that
expression from a conversation to a
feature film is always difficult to do
it well requires a measure of
composition of time and a willingness to
improve despite frustrations distracting
your social media personality is not you
it's a performance of you and maybe for
yourself is easy not to confuse that
difference but it's not so easy for all
those who see only this performance and
who are disposed in many ways to treat
others as stereotypically as they can
and maybe sometimes you get frustrated
feeling that others don't understand you
don't see or respect what you want maybe
you feel like you're always coming out
of conversations or arguments with your
point poorly made well I'll let you in
on a secret
those who can speak well to the point
and with lucidity practice these people
trip up like everyone else but less
but more times than not they make their
point and come out of even a normal
conversation feeling like you have a
better understanding of what they want
and who they are not everyone is or has
to be an artist not everyone has to
write a novel or make an album but there
is something to be said for a little bit
of reserve when it comes to expression
that way you can preserve some of your
own mystery some of your own subtlety
you can escape some unnecessary judgment
and you can recover the power of your
own voice oh sorry
just getting a tweet what could she
possibly be painting